Okay, hopefully I'm not too big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big,
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big,
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big,
big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big,
I have a shotcaller on and I have a heart rate monitor on, bottom left is my heart rate,
high and the shotcaller is around my thigh because I'm worried about my neck because
I have a few heart conditions, underlying heart conditions but that's okay, it's the
kind that I'm going to be okay.
So we're going to play on normal mode and I'm pretty sure they have an easy-peasy mode.
Yeah, okay, so we're going to do normal, we're going to do start with normal but hello hi.
I'm going to do it without a timer because we're not doing...
So we've got fucking everything alright?
Okay, we've got everything.
I'm just going to put everything on so it's a fucking shot in the dark.
Okay, there's a baby mode, we're like 2 plus 2, that's exactly what we're doing.
This is probably the only one I'm going to win on.
Howdy, my favourite Scottish fish pimp.
No, you can't call me that, that's only...
Don't you shock yourself to the point of heart.
I'll be okay.
I do have a cup of tea.
So if you saw it, Maryse Modisse did have an ASMR role play up.
Unfortunately the subtitles messed up and she wasn't satisfied with it so
I've elected to take it down, I will fix it, so be prepared tomorrow.
Why are you shocking yourself?
Every time I get something wrong I'm going to trade my brain to be right only.
If I am wrong I will zap myself and cause a pain response in my mind
which means that my brain will automatically pick the correct answer
even if it doesn't know what the correct answer is.
I will use all the collective and accumulative knowledge in my travels
which is not much because let's be honest, I sat on the Xbox all my life.
So that's how we're doing it, okay?
I do have an announcement for Snow Berries.
AC recorded a YouTube role play ASMR so if she gives me the green light
I will upload that to refill some copium levels.
I assure you AC has missed you as much as you have missed her.
Snow Berries, okay?
Oh you agreed with me on the short.
I thought that, I was like didn't I reply to a comment that was exactly like that?
Yes, I have a new short out where I stutter if you've not seen it
but I'm going to have, I'm going to drink my tea.
Reflings, my aim tonight, my little goal is I'm going to collab with Said.
I'm going to finish that collab and I'm going to do the pregnancy ASMR as well
so I've got my work cut out for me but that's not going to stop me.
Then they're going to stop me because I'm such a hard worker.
After this stream we're doing shock ASMR.
I don't know how it's going to work.
It's not going to be an ASMR stream, let's all freaking admit it.
But yes, my goal is I'm going to do the AC audio one collab with me
and my pregnant with you ASMR.
A little bit of work but we're getting there.
The third audio editor is actually going to be Ed and AC
and just need to hand over all the like SFX and stuff and her lines and that
but AC's been doing a lot of work behind the scenes.
Holy moly.
She was like here's all these audios and here's this YouTube roleplay as well.
If you have any more just send them away.
I'm like ooh.
Okay.
I'm going to send them to them.
You don't have to tell me twice.
I'm going to see if I can convince her to maybe do a recorded thing in my barber.
Hi. Hi, we're playing.
Hi, Stroni. I can't wait for the thunder.
Give me the zap.
Content factory. Yes.
And I have very funny news about her membership name.
Now if you go and look on AC's membership name it says Snow Berries right now.
She just submitted to me a message 10 minutes ago on what she wants to change it to
and I said right not right now because I just changed her name and YouTube gave me a heart attack
because it was like it needs to go through approval.
But what she sent me was rather interesting.
Shot caller. It's on my leg.
Like I don't know if you can hear this.
That's the device.
It's got like a little knobbly, bobbly bit at the top and all that.
She's been something about getting a blowjob with a whole knee.
Okay, we're just going to go for it.
This is the warm up okay.
I will shock myself either way but this is the warm up.
I call me Big Julie why I know.
My passion is being social.
Did I turn that down?
The way I love words coming out of my mouth.
I'm so social.
The way I love just hearing my voice.
Press any button and continue.
This is the warm up as I have my tea.
I just dropped my tea everywhere.
I went on the shot caller.
Why am I like this replay?
Oh my God.
Oh, damn.
I don't know if it's like this.
Mail on stream.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Dry it, you may get it destroyed.
It didn't go in the electronical part.
It went on the strap.
Thank you for having chosen me.
Let's play who wants to be a millionaire.
Oh my God, I've got heels on another hand.
You know the money ladder and it's 15 steps to reach the million.
Just need to get 15 questions right.
We can do it.
Okay, okay.
Call and be a lawyer.
Ask the audience and flip the question.
Here's a new question for you.
Which sitcom character's favourite superhero is the Flash?
Sheldon Cooper, I think.
I actually know that one.
Excuse me, sir.
I'd like to look and see Sheldon Cooper.
I'm going to choose C.
I'm pretty sure it's the Flash.
Did I not select it?
Well, I was pranking him.
I touched it, but I didn't select.
That's my final answer.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I can't wait to see the correct answer.
Oh, I can't wait.
Yes!
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Do I have to shock myself just yet?
We believe it.
It's climbing quickly.
100 smacker rings.
Oh, I'm rich.
I'm getting Russian chips tonight.
All of her twists.
Okay, we do know this one.
I've almost finished the tea.
All of her twists.
I do know this one.
Okay.
Do you want the lambara?
I'll show you the lambara.
Let's go with the right answer and therefore...
Therefore...
I feel like she'd be with absolutely Neil Harper.
All of her twists, my boy.
Yes, that's my final answer.
I'm a fucking streamdecker.
Hold on, let me put my streamdecker.
Hold on.
For everyone to forget, I tried to make that joke.
More like all of her twists, my balls.
No, audience, don't clap over my joke.
And go on to the next one.
No, audience, you're laughing up on my joke.
Let's go for a whole new question.
Also, I just want to say a warning right now.
The likelihood of me farting is very high.
Constipated and receiving pain is going to make me expel fucking air at my ass.
I don't know how to say it.
In the spelling of words in English,
my biggest weakness, which letter almost always falls Q?
It's actually you.
Qeen.
Queen is the biggest example.
Final answer?
That was a great joke.
Also, thanks for the heads up.
Literally...
That's my final answer.
I'm breaded again.
I'm literally just shoving water up more so I don't even care.
I'm so tired.
Just own it.
You've got it.
Just a little golf clap.
Thank you.
I'll be here all week.
I need to keep a close eye out.
Oh, gosh.
A slap shot.
A volleyball sounds like a slap shot.
Like slap it down really quickly.
What the fuck is handball?
I would say volleyball.
Surely volleyball is when you slap it down really quickly.
It's either handball or volleyball.
I've never seen handball.
No one knows what handball is.
And on that basis, it's volleyball.
Because I've never seen handball in my life.
I know basketball is.
I'm going to cry if I have to shock myself so quickly.
Bro, looking.
Looking.
Ironically.
But it's the game.
This is not the right answer.
Oh, no.
Well, let's put things in perspective.
What is hockey slap?
Oh, my God.
Fortunately, it's all over.
Right.
Okay.
It's fine.
Hold on.
I think the anticipation is going to be worse than what it is.
I think then.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great.
Okay.
The anticipation is the worst bit.
That's what it is.
Are you ready?
I don't know if you can hear this click.
Okay.
I could probably handle a bit more if I'm being honest.
I'll put it up by one next time.
Okay.
But there you go.
I got fucking wrong.
Like a dumb ass.
Right.
We know what the intro is like.
And we know what the...
Sorry.
I'm really bad with pain.
I was like such a wee wimp, honestly.
Right.
So we can kind of skip through the actual, like, all this stuff.
Okay.
So we're going to skip all this bit because we've already done this bit.
And which of these would you keep your valuables in a safe?
Surely.
This is just straight up in English.
Oh, your gambon on D.
No, no.
It turned Yelp.
I'm going to sound like Tom and Jerry by the end of the stream.
If the button gets stuck, I can pull it off.
Thanks, Holly.
A harmless.
No, stop it.
Who am I supposed to know?
Oh.
Amy.
Merci.
Obliette.
Okay.
It's true.
But if I was born French, I'd be called Pierre.
Who would go...
Who would birth a child to be like,
I have a child and I am French speaking.
I will call him Justine.
Like, no, it's Pierre.
Who's going to call there Wayne Justin?
Like, that's not going to work.
Yes, it's my final answer.
Thank you.
Yes.
That's my final answer.
Justine, my child.
Okay.
The computer validated your answer.
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh, no, it's drawn out.
Oh, why would you spawn a child and call it Justine?
Do you want that thing to be bullied?
We had to play the card of cause.
Why would you spawn and go...
Nothing.
I'm sorry for you.
Bravo.
It's Cubic for...
No, I've got to add three.
Fuck.
Right.
Okay.
It's fine.
I've got to add three.
I can do it.
Okay.
It's fine.
So the anticipation is what gets you the most.
Okay.
It's anticipation.
Right.
You ready?
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm actually scared.
Right.
Okay.
I'm starting to set.
I'm going to put it up to four.
It's then one four because I did it on one.
I felt it.
Oh my God.
I need to move it like around the thigh area though.
I don't want it all in one place.
Okay.
Let's go again.
Again, again, again.
Surely.
Surely will win.
Copy on me.
I'm going to have to play easy mode.
Okay.
We're on number four.
There's 10 seconds on this.
Although the instructions were fucked.
Let me just tell you the instructions were really bad.
They were like, oh, if your dog starts yelping, like remove the device immediately and discontinue
its use.
It's not to be used like that.
And it was just sad that folk even had to like pop that thing down.
Oh, God.
Man, you popped up on another can.
Time for this new question.
Bro.
It's time to get your tentacles sucked.
Which of these is another name for a private detective?
A private eye.
I'm choosing A.
Copy on me.
I have faith.
Mods knew that man at the stratosphere.
He's literally got OBS on.
And he's tried to record all like the vealer talents.
And he's like, let's see.
Vealer Laminers.
Like from complete play some video games.
Relax.
Which verb means to tap your fingers repetitively?
What verb is they're doing?
Oh, to drum your fingers.
But if it's a piano, it would do your fingers.
A viola is eee.
And a flute is eee.
A drum's you bang it.
I assume it's piano.
It has to be piano.
You didn't drum your fingers.
It is.
You can't always win.
That makes no sense.
Who drums their fingers on the fucking table?
Why would you drum your fingers on the table?
Oh, excuse.
Oh, sorry for distracting you.
I was just drumming my fingers on the table.
What you on about?
That's not even English.
Like, you piano a key.
Because that's the way pianos look when you're touching a piano.
Right, okay.
Level four, okay?
It's fine.
Who fucking pianos their table?
Well, who fucking...
No drum is tapping.
It didn't say tap.
Right, ready?
Three, two, one.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We can go higher.
Can we get much higher?
Okay, we're on five now.
Absolute copium.
We're on five.
It's fine.
I can handle it.
Right, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
I'm like breaking out in a sweat.
Fucking...
Right, who...
Oh, come on!
Who is Scrooge's nephew?
Donald Duck, I think.
It's Donald, I think.
I never saw that one because I didn't...
I wasn't even a twinkle in my...
I think it's Donald.
I think it's Donald!
I think so.
Yes, okay.
Oh, thank God.
Right, we're safe.
We're safe.
I'm no good with this name.
I needed to keep my cool and it paid off.
Oh, I didn't keep my cool.
How did Caviar Lime get its name?
What is Caviar Lime?
It contains little bowls that resemble Caviar.
It tastes like Caviar.
It is as expensive as Caviar.
It is black like Caviar.
What is Caviar Lime?
I've never heard of it.
Oh, my God.
What would Caviar Lime be?
A bar drink?
It's expensive as Caviar.
Why would you buy a bar drink that's expensive as Caviar?
It is black like Caviar.
No, it's not Tapioca.
How did Caviar L...
Who is Caviar Lime?
When were you born and why is that your fucking name?
What the fuck?
It's black like Caviar.
It's expensive as Caviar.
It tastes like...
How am I supposed to know that?
I don't even know.
It's C. Can I just cheat?
Am I allowed to cheat?
I was going to say D.
It's a fruit!
Oh, of course the fucking Scottish scurvy fucking afflicted Scott
wouldn't know what a fucking Caviar Lime is.
Oh, it's a Lime!
Oh, I thought it was like a car.
I'm going to be on it.
I thought it was a car like a drink.
Am I allowed to cheat and say C?
Can I cheat and say C even though I was going to say D?
No, put D.
This is cheating.
I didn't understand this.
Oh my God, I didn't...
I fucking had to...
Right, okay.
In my defense.
Right, this is five.
Okay.
Oh, I'm actually getting nervous.
Three...
Two...
One...
Okay, okay.
I can manage.
The worst thing is, it's not one shock.
It's...
Like, that's how the shock is administered.
So just when you think you're going to feel it for like once,
it goes like,
Oh, here's another one, bitch.
It's like...
Bruv.
Caviar Lime, of course it was a fruit.
But I thought it was like...
You know how like...
I don't know.
I can't even think of an example right now.
I can't even think of an example.
I got up to 145.
John Omni, thank you so much.
Anonymous tips, Johnny.
What in the world is piano a verb?
It makes more sense for your fingers.
It said move your fingers.
Oh my God, Zara, please help me.
What's not a shonen?
Berserker, surely.
Because Dragon Ball goes on forever.
One piece goes on forever.
Naruto went on forever.
So it's Berserker.
That's how it goes.
If a shonen means that the show goes on for far too fucking long,
and then they need to wrap it up, okay?
They need to wrap it up,
and Berserker got wrapped up, okay?
And this is my logic...
It worked!
My logic worked!
It's because they didn't wrap up!
What does IOC mean?
What's the IOU?
Get wrecked.
Get wrecked, weebs.
Well, I've never heard of IOC.
Right.
International Organization of Challengers.
That sounds like some weird Guinness World Book of Records.
International Olympic Committee.
Oh, that sounds much more likely.
International Order...
Oh, okay.
It's Olympics.
A is going to be the right answer.
I'm literally Skippity-Doodle-Dun.
Yeah, sorry.
That was too easy.
He's a piece of enthusiasm.
With which branch of the arts
is Vincent Van Gogh most associated?
Pain and I.
And then he chopped his wee ear lobe off.
That's right.
He did a wee pain,
and he was like,
oh, you know what,
they make this a masterpiece come together.
Chopping my ear lobe off.
All right, all right, all right.
Oh.
Yes, that's my final...
Oh, okay.
I'm actually so smart.
If...
Where are you,
if you're ordering a Wienerschnitzel?
Deutschland?
Ja?
A Wienerschnitzel?
How do you say it in German?
And now to the most important question of all.
Surely it's not a misnomer,
and it was like, oh, by the way,
it was actually created in Austria,
because they speak German in Austria as well.
Surely, kopium.
Kopium before it's a fucking fake out.
Um, okay.
Ah, it's a fake out!
They speak...
They speak German in Austria.
Why?
A fucking Wienerschnitzel is a most stereotypical
like, October face thing ever.
Why?
Why are all of these things
fucking like, tee-hee, tee-hee?
Right, what level are we on?
Oh, my God, we're on number six.
Okay.
Okay, we can do it.
We can do it, we're on number six.
I love number six.
October face is Dutch.
Okay, that's the...
Oh, God, okay.
Right.
I can do number six, okay?
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
That was, uh-huh, I even felt that.
That's got a little kick to it.
It's got a little kick to it.
It's okay.
It's okay, got a little kick to it.
It's just...
It's just in the season, you know?
But the food is good overall.
Oh, right, normal.
No time for fucking schnitzel, yeah, pal.
Oh, I'd like one Wienerschnitzel, please.
Oh, you must be in Austria.
Excuse me, I thought it took a plane to Berlin.
What's going on here?
Where did I go?
I disappeared.
Fucking Wienerschnitzel.
I'm gonna go a bed mad over Wienerschnitzel tonight.
I just thought you should know.
Shawnee, please don't make it too high.
Just do like three or four wrong answers.
Subtitles?
No, don't put it up more.
Oh, I wanted to do it on ten.
Is that bad?
Or is that weird?
Crank it to the max.
Yeah, I was gonna go up to the max.
And then I put it back down to, like, what I can handle.
Wien is the capital of Austria.
Who played...
Oh, my God.
Which actress played Wonder Woman?
Galal Gadot.
Yeah.
Haley Berry was stormed in X-Men.
Scarlet Wood, Johansson was Black Widow.
I'm sorry, Charlize, stay her on, but I don't know who you are.
Oh, yeah.
It's bigger, too.
How are the continents represented on the Olympic flag?
By the circles?
By the rings?
Okay, by the rings.
I'm gonna go with by the rings.
Thank you, my good sir.
Oh, yes.
Haley Berry was also captain.
Ah, what musical group album
did you put in Rumors Tusk and Behind the Mask?
Refland's Kanachi, I don't...
Oh, Fleetwood Mac.
Mac, it's Fleetwood Mac, okay.
Let's take a deep breath.
I'm confident that it's C.
Okay, I was lucky that they gave me the answer like that.
If it didn't give me the answer like that, it was ogre.
It was actually ogre.
But they gave me it like that, so I'll take it.
What is Usain Bolt's nickname?
I want to say lightning bolt.
I want to say running bolt, that's shit.
Speedy bolt. Super bolt.
Oh, look, here he comes.
It's running bolt.
No, like lightning bolt. It has to be.
I have faith.
Yeah, okay, thank goodness.
I was gonna say, I was like, oh, that's weird.
Which Olympic symbol is passed from hand to hand
during the opening ceremony?
Ah, touch. It's lit up like the sky.
They're all shit, buddy.
Oh my God, we made a thousand.
I just got an achievement for the first time
to reach 5,000, 1,000 quid.
That's how bad I've been playing.
On television, Oz Clark is best known as a egg.
Who is Oz Clark?
Identify yourself.
DIY horse racing?
Fashion?
Wayne.
It has to be DIY.
Horse racing?
Is this an Australian?
Oz Clark.
Right, Clark rhymes with a hammer.
Okay, DIY.
I don't know.
You can't be an expert on TV about
Wayne or fashion or horse racing.
That doesn't make sense.
That's my final answer.
I love the way the horse...
I say giddy up to the horsey.
That doesn't make any sense.
Who?
What?
No, I'll be faster.
Oh, I'm an expert in Wayne, by the way.
Wayne?
It's just fermented grapes.
Are you joking?
Who was supposed to know that?
Oh, I got a whole 40 points for that, though.
Totally didn't...
He's Brett?
Oh, my God.
Literally, like, oh, I'm so good at tasting Wayne.
That aroma up my nose.
Like, what you on about?
It's just fucking nasty drink.
Right, are we ready for level seven?
Okay.
I can do it.
Don't forget the lifelines I showed.
Okay, ready?
Three...
Two...
One...
Okay!
I'm going up to the number eight now.
There's only ten levels as far as I'm aware.
Unless we're about to unlock the secret DLC levels on the damn thing.
But...
Oh, we're doing it!
We're doing it!
I'm going to move it around on the next part of my thigh
because I don't want any issues.
Okay, normal.
No time mark because I don't want to feel rushed.
Next...
Yulie.
We're going all out on Lili and Yulie.
Car battery DLC.
Hack it and go 15 star.
That's terrible.
Terrible.
Put that on me.
I don't know if the game...
Is the game in me loud enough?
Like, is it a bit confidential?
Anyway.
What phrase is often used to describe senior company executives?
Big nasty bastard.
Big nasty bastard hedge fund fuckers.
Um, sorry.
I believe they're referred to fat cats.
I'll take fat cats for ten, please.
I know you are waiting.
You may get lucky.
You've got it.
It's time to move on to a new question.
Who gave birth to a boy named Deacon Philippe in the fall of 2003?
Reese Witherspoon is my guess based on what's popping up.
Yeah, okay.
Grease Sugarspoon.
One that's incredibly rude.
But I'll take it.
Thank God.
I'm going to start calling them the big bunnies.
I took the time I needed, but at least the results are there.
Eh, right.
Which Italian cheese used on people stretches...
Used on people?
Oh my God.
People that hit each of our people?
Mozzarella.
I stretch it.
It's got gooey.
It's got gooey on the pizza.
Thank you.
Okay, clap, clap, clap.
Go clap.
Thank you.
What year appears in the title of Stanley Kubrick's film subtitled?
I think it's 2001, the Space Odyssey?
Well, it's death.
Wait, is it?
2001, the Space Odyssey?
2000...
1979, the Space Odyssey.
1945, the Space Odyssey.
1984, the Space Odyssey.
No, it's 2001.
Yeah.
2000, because it was supposed to be set in the future.
I've actually not seen that film.
I wanted to watch it, were you?
But I don't have a chance to watch it.
Well, we're watching stuff soon.
Yeah, okay.
Right, safe.
Get ready.
I'm not getting shocked.
Our team of editors...
I do.
Which of these is the device used with a computer to digitize...
Is that a joke?
Or is this real?
Is this what they consider technology questions?
Like, a scanner?
Do you know what the scooping room is used for?
For scooping, you fucking idiot!
What?
That's a FNAF reference for you.
A zoomer.
Oh my god, we made a thousand quid!
This is the farthest I've ever gone.
Zoomer is a U of PIC scanner, by the way.
Everyone knows the Empire's Thai hunters.
What does Thai mean?
Huh?
What?
Everyone knows the Empire.
Who the fuck is the Empire, buddy?
Star Wars?
What?
The only Empire I'm aware of is Star Wars,
and last time I checked, we defeated the baddies.
So...
What's going on?
Empire's Thai hunters.
Who's...
Twin Iron Engines,
Task Ion Energy,
Task Industry Engineer.
The Empire's Task Industry Engineer.
What?!
Is that a reference to the Roman Empire?
Yeah, we decommissioned them.
Okay, right, I'll take that hint.
If we decommissioned them, then it's engines.
Whatever the F that is.
Whose Empire are we even referring to?
Task Ion Energy.
No, if we decommissioned them, it's engines.
The Empire's two engine hunters.
I don't know why that's specific though,
and why you need to mention that.
What even is that?
Who would even get that question?
Sorry, I feel like completely cheatsy doodles.
Okay, I've got a 2,000 quid thought.
What is the name?
Oh, no.
Diny's Diny.
Uh...
Just gonna warn you, don't watch...
Oh, no, is my freaking audio broken?
Oops.
Is Brian...
Brian!
Nothing happens the whole movie.
There's a six-minute scene with only loud breathing.
Is there a...wait, hold on.
Brian, can you say that again?
You got a little shy, buddy.
Brian, go again.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Alright, Brian, tell us what you...
Tell...what are you preachin'?
Just gonna warn you, don't watch 2001.
A space odyssey on stream.
It's the most boring movie existence.
It has some cool camera work,
but is awful to watch since basically
nothing happens the whole movie.
There's a six-minute scene with only loud breathing.
That's what space odyssey's about.
Thank you, Diny's Diny.
Okay, we ain't watchin' Diny's Diny.
What is the name of Copper's owner
and the fox and the...
I think it's Tweet.
I want to say it's Tweet.
Tweet?
Because Amos Salade is Spanish, right?
And Fox and the Hound isn't set for Spain.
So Amos say Tweet.
I'm confident that it's C.
Okay, we're PDC.
Let me know. Let me know what you think.
Why?
It's not even a Spanish film!
Please, if I look up Salade
and Salade's surname, origin,
I'm actually gonna pop.
It's not set in Spain!
It's a Saxon...
Oh!
It's fuckin' English!
Fuck!
It's an English spawned name.
It says Saxon on the web.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine. It's fine.
It's fine.
Ready? This is number eight.
Okay, number eight.
Okay.
Set up for this one.
Ready?
Three, two, one...
Okay!
That is...
That is a...
That is a Chocorini.
I have to admit that is...
You'll never guess what.
It's actually a Chocorini.
Quite literally.
Okay.
Okay, we're going up to nine.
We're going up to nine.
It's nine.
No, I love that.
It's so dumb that I don't get anywhere in this game.
No!
It's hilarious.
Fuckin' Saladi.
I've never heard that surname.
Shock and behavior.
From how terrible my freakin' knowledge is on anything.
I think I'm gonna have to start taking out categories that didn't even came.
Okay.
Which of these is an informal name for a party?
A crash.
I'm sure of it.
It has to be a crash.
Like, oh.
A bash?
That's my final name.
Oh no, is it bash?
Is it bash?
Hold on.
Oh my god!
Right!
A bash.
Go for a birthday bash.
You idiot!
Right.
Okay.
Nine.
I'm sorry.
I'm literally a birthday bash.
A crash bash.
Okay.
I'm a bit nervous about number nine.
I'm gonna be honest.
If this is literally the second-last level before...
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh my god!
That is so sore.
Don't ever use this on your pets.
What the fuck?
Are you squidding me right now?
That's fucked.
Don't ever use short-quality on your pets.
Oh wait, what does that mean?
Your braid of Frankenstein.
Wait, what's the braid of Frankenstein?
Stop!
What's the braid of Frankenstein?
What's that mean?
Oh, what does that mean, Adam?
Thank you, the bitty lord.
Ninety-six.
Ninety-six is the bitty lord backwards.
What name?
Oh my god, the hair!
Okay, that's actually a really good reference.
Sorry.
Hold on, let me...
That's such a good reference.
Her hair's up.
Okay, that's really good.
I'll give you that.
Okay, we're on level ten now.
Copy on.
Oh, that's got a last and tingle on my leg.
I'm gonna be honest, I can actually still kind of feel that.
Right.
I will start swapping the stuff around once I've reached max level,
and we're gonna go down a bit.
Are you squidding me right now?
Okay.
Oh!
Thank you, Dan Sullivan, for the tip.
Refunds have it.
I can't believe it.
The reflings are infighting!
That's true.
Thank you for becoming a member.
Please enjoy the perks.
I don't know how I'm supposed to shock myself
on the ASMR stream after this stream.
It's not even possible.
How am I supposed to quietly shock myself?
I have no idea.
I have absolutely no idea.
Which of these is most likely to be marketed as lead free?
Oh.
Well.
Well then, well then.
Did we not discover that it was a lot more lead
than we thought in the official pipeline of things?
Gee, I wonder which massive fucking mega corporations
wanted to hide that news from the people.
Which household object is most likely to have a hob on top?
A cooker?
Aye, a cooker.
Okay, a cooker.
Any hobbers?
Anyone got their hob knobs out?
I've got my hob knob out.
Hob knob is a biscuit in the UK before anyone's like,
what are you on about?
A hob is the rings on top of the stove
with the little thing around it.
It's the piano?
Are you trying to shock me?
Of course it's not the piano.
Which of these is...
Which of these is villains is...
What? Wait, is that me or is that the game?
Which of these is villains is not from the...
Alright, shut up.
Okay, the Joker is DC.
The Bane is DC.
Galactus and Lex Luthor.
I don't know who these people are.
Ah.
It didn't equal a good film.
Thank you, tiny spainy.
Yeah, Reefling, stop the infighting.
You know, when Veeler started,
we got like lots of comments like,
oh, the infighting between the girls is going to be intense.
I can't believe it.
The infighting was with the fucking Reeflings all along.
It's not even the streamer.
Ah!
Okay.
Now, I'm totally not cheating.
I'm taking Galactus to heat.
I'm on level 10 of the shocker.
Right, I'm on level 10 of the shocker.
Give me...
Which word refers to land
which is suitable for growing crops?
Fair tale.
Risible?
Wait, oh no.
I don't know this one.
Risible?
You want to...
Hey, little crops.
You want to propagate for me, baby girl?
Risible land.
That's awful.
I'm going to have to cheat, see, doodle
and actually do...
Audience!
Right.
Boom!
Arabal land.
Any arabal landers.
What's dragon trainer?
Are you speaking to me right now?
Wait, what?
Ignore tiny spiny.
He doesn't understand the movie
or the community don't claim his whack.
Copinion.
Thank you, Karen Quist.
Pay for roasting the Reeflings.
For his opinion on the movie,
he's getting annihilated.
He's going to be the right answer.
Okay, arabal land.
Not to be confused with...
Ara...
I thought it was fair tale land.
But I'll take it.
Clap, clap, go clap.
I'm assuming dragon trainer's time to train your dragon.
Ah, yeah.
Oh.
I might read that book unironically.
I've not read a book in a while.
I miss reading.
But I don't have time to read.
But I'll read soon.
How about that?
In which combat sport?
Thank you for that anonymous...
Did I say thank you?
I think I said thank you, thank you.
In which combat sport is the
Look!
You used to learn how to know when you're ready.
Look, are you ready, my lord?
Did I do it right?
Yes, exactly.
Thank you.
Shvers...
donc?
Shvers!
R Amazing.
write a 2000 word essay telling us what you learned oh oh you're getting spanked
about you're getting spanked about what's going on riefling on riefling
violence you love to see it you love to see it literally anonymous thank you for
the tip Jackson Shaw thank you for the tip absolutely getting spanked about in
there and which Disney Sheddington doesn't have a star
2001 by Arthur C. Clarke and watch the movie by Kubrick smile thank you math
for the suggestion read a book read the book let me read it then if it's a if
his book is small I might be able to squeeze it in I feel like literally had
to throw all my although gaming is a passion of mine so is it really look
before I start getting into the old argument as is V-tribbing work not
really and right who doesn't have a star tinkerbell will not oh balloon it's
either tinkerbell or balloon so tinkerbell has been a reoccurring character
whereas below has not actually I really like the tinkerbell series and I would
like to watch tinkerbell run your own streams dudes I am trying to watch
thank you don't say that I'm gonna say below because below and the jungle book
never got its extension if that makes sense whereas tinkerbell has her own
spin-off series she's literally in the intro to Disney that's her big
sprinkle in the thingy so below all thanks
in 2004 who had the top ten hit song with the song toxic
you're toxic I'm the biggest poison paradise I'm addicted to you cuz you know that I'm toxic
I will may back down there are plenty of good long and old movies Kubrick has
plenty of good ones and 2001 is well-directed but it's a terrible plot
not sorry I may be crucified for it but I stand by it thank you tiny spany
always look on the bright side of life and I want to miss if we're all fighting
let's turn it into free for all brawl winner gets the ink inside strongy this
roof one's gonna become a crack oh my god the thank you notice they let her ass
absolute breed of dog originated in Nepal or Taipei it's either Taipei I think
I bet me right now if it's that big fluffy I have not seen the movie and
therefore have no opinion on it but I would watch anything with you strongy
and have a good time are you squiddin me right now 2001 the space odyssey is a
masterpiece in philosophy you guys were about to be one of the best movies of
all time you just got to take time to understand oh fuck gaming kids any thank
you for the chip and an honest right now hear me out we're asking about dog
breeds okay there's only one correct person we can ask and that's the white
woman I will not explain any further I know questions
I need your help we're going to do our best go on tell me everything but only if
you go as far as possible no worries that's what I'm here what the fuck I would
say be Taipei okay okay Taipei okay Taipei Taipei okay D on route to the win
I'll root is that bum for you are you squiddin me right now that's my final answer you'll
are losing the plot chill haha I have her thank you okay oh wait women got the
question right about dogs actually car in 4k oh 8000 oh this is the most we've
ever made oh my god now let's go to the next this debate is 100% getting cut
please include me in your short I'm gonna watch Shrek one we are boy thank you
for the extended membership tip thank you founded in 1942 by what name is the
Oxford committee for famine relief known oh Oxfam Oxfam I'm confident that I'm
I'm a spondent Scotland I can with this right I can what the scene is at Oxfam
because they're always like putting ads on the telly and all that I'm gonna be
honest I know you guys can't see it is so scary looking down and seeing a
flashing blinking device on my thigh ready to shock me at any moment okay
we're on 16 grand this is the most we've made so far what be a telly a telly a
television telly the telly on the big telly and Shawnee needs in real-life
lifelines a look at chat be phone her gen mate see 10 seconds ago go honestly
though which American offer sent a cable from Europe saying the report of my
death was an exaggeration on reading his own obituary Fitzgeralds or John
Steinbeck are the only two names I know I think John Steinbeck did play
writing I once watched the entire Shrek speed up to last 15 minutes in a 10 by
10 pixelated window anyways answer is a for Europe thank you ask you for your
advice on E for sure right right I'm gonna have to cheat see that all I don't
know what is what they'll have any more lifelines I have I have leave with the
money what shit lifeline right give me 50 50 to random wrong and then we get a
true 50 50 so if I get it wrong and get it wrong you know what I'm saying right
so Fitzgerald wrote the Green Gatsby I don't know who Mark Twain is I'm so sorry
I'm not familiar with your work my good sir even though you popped your clogs
pen TN the refling council officially declares the reef games nothing is true
everything is permitted the survivor shall be named refling prime the Empress
protect anonymous WG have to have no idea what I mean oh is that one supposed to
submit okay tween the dude who wrote Huckleberry Finn oh Huckleberry Finn
versus the great Gatsby I think Huckleberry wins and popularity I think
Huckleberry wins I'm going to Huckleberry sorry I think the up against the
great Gatsby that's my good film good book but I think Huckleberry I've never
read Huckleberry but everyone was on about it you're my uncle bear the right
answer okay oh I just got a cheap man I'm in the way but I just let me take that
for the Empress okay I hope you ever covered from your emotions because
your new question actor Zaza Gabber was the great aunt of which of our celebrity
who knows the fucking sorry what we saying help chat what does send a cable
mean I think it means like an old-timey message and right I'm gonna be honest
who knows the lineage and family trees of celebrities right so Zaza Gabber okay
doesn't sound like originated in like our western country right here a nightly
as white as a pancake Scarlett Johansson's white but she's mixed with
son Paris Hilton's white be you oh my god the head feature for be you okay
remember that time she wanted to call her fan base pebble files I cannot get
over that how funny she is I cannot get over how funny that moment was I will
never get over how funny that moment was I will never shut up about it little
bebo I will never shut up about how funny that moment was okay I was gobsmacked
she no so they they had just debuted for like a month or something like that and
then bebo came out with like should I come in fan base pebble files and then
obviously it got pulled by management cuz like there's no way they would have
got away with that I was gobsmacked I was like I love it I'm I'm not even I'm
not even I brought I will I will go to the death for bebo just for that one
remark alone I will go to the death for her it was pebble pale not fail close
enough zaza is white who right wait what okay that changes the question if
zaza is white then who would name if it's a family of weird names now Bijou
isn't a weird name it's just foreign something sense why is none of their
surnames gobor it was a great aunt right so it's the lineage how not I even have
any help what I have refresh question is that not just straight to him it's
pretty zaa so zaza Bijou is French
a stony it's good I caught fish and I played right can I just skip a question
and ironically so let's flip a question hoping it will inspire you you can flip
a question okay who who even would know that sorry but who even goes like oh I
can who's more than cousins twice removed from this one celebrity like gonna be real
for one minute
I've no read that book smoking was a bubble's blowing zaza thank you for the
subject what is the name of the orphan that Bernard and Bianca right we've got
too many bees off the bat and the bayou so it's not really a bee and we've got a
D as well okay so B and D are like second and fourth in the alphabet so A B
C D E F okay and then the closest to F is Jenny right that's how it works so Jenny
I'm choosing a let's go that's how logic works baby so let's go this is gonna be
horrifically wrong answer gonna be horrifically wrong I'm getting shocked on
level 10 I have accepted my fate because I don't know even what that was by
you I'm still I'm still Jenny from the black yeah penny yeah yeah yeah no one's
fucking read the devil's fire okay I'm gonna put both feet on the ground to
prepare myself for this one cuz I am nervous okay this is 10
and as an all the our key and I'm a poll that you forgot twin forgive me the
milkman for my milk was not delicious on the stage right this is level 10 I
believe this is the max level it's staring at me blinking okay three two
one
ass dear ass dear I could dear I gave three attempts at your name thank you so
much for the 10 gifted memberships and to congrats to those who caught it with
your face it goes up reeflings it goes past 10 I thought 10 was the freakin we
literally you mispronounce Ozar key I am I've never seen that word in my life
please forgive me thank you again for the 10 gifted memberships is a cadia
ass idea I'm trying oh god I don't know why anyone would put that on their neck
though I would not recommend okay we're still not at the max level of shock so
we're gonna keep going until we reach the max level of shock okay because I
don't know what it is and it's just gonna be a surprise on the other side or
do you want me to check what level it goes up to checks and shot it's electric
movie movie a very tall building in a sky is called the sky scraper scraper
hardly even nor you want me to check the max level right okay hold on I'm
checking now
oh my god that wasn't a fucking button to I just just shocked myself that wasn't a button to turn the level off
I just shocked myself right it goes past 20 oh my god they are a 40 no no fucker 50
what the fuck oh my god it goes up to 70 no go back down before I accidentally
frickin do that it goes up to 99 most likely what I'm on a live in no my
neighbors are probably gonna call the freaking police on me I'm on a live in
well that put on 12 because I technically shocked myself on a live in
or dad do it again and do it colors you're gonna faint if you do that is that
used for actual torture it's used to train dogs that embark or do stuff you
don't want them to do it's 11 not 12 stay on a live in
I'm begging you do not go higher than 10 please go back down to
tiny spainy but if it goes up to 100 then I'm not even like 50% of the way
do not use this on your dog no you bought that on the dark wave what now
it's a dog collar it's to train animals but don't actually use it strongy 100
should we do 100 at the end on ironically I'm kind of tempted to do it
I'm actually tempted to do 100 just to be like yeah I did it 100 on my short
collar you know what who does Marilyn face and a shape-shifting wizard do no
please and why are you using a dog toy because if you use a human one ask for
your phone number and all your personal data and it tracks it and sends it in
packages it to China don't ask me I'm just here for the good time okay the
milkman I cast band of lightning honestly though deep right okay who does
Marilyn face in the shape-shifting wizards do I can't be Maleficent because
that's a different IP madam mem lady Terra mine and aunt Sarah and it sounds a
bit specific please do not do a hundred people come and pasted it likely will
permanent nerve damage what how can they sell these then can I cheat already
I'm not right can I phone in the reef ones tonight can I have a secret cheat
here and then there's this symbol low here and it goes calling the reef ones
that I don't know what this is either a or d also they couldn't have sold it if
it was really about dogs have fair go down preferably five yes don't need they
are banned for a very good reason damn straighter beer skin isn't going to be
the same one for as fur is D it's a oh my god I have to pick either one I think
madam mem sounds like something from Marilyn like Marilyn versus madam mean
I'm a gambler and so I am a gambler oh my god you play about so too hey I can't
I just take my D which of these sports is played on horseback polo polo
polo
j'ai alia what pourquoi a franais j'ai alia I am alia I have alia what is alia
to say I have in French you say je like j'ai a I with the me a post or
excuse oh a Star Wars I was all I saw on my brain so it was terrorist attack and
I was like we're asking questions about what now the targeted who replaced
Padme in the galactic said what then targeted by who replaced Padme in the
galactic Senate in order to ensure her safety was it did Georgia no Georgia
wasn't in wait I'm gonna mental Center Palpatine's the bad day bail
organo it should be be I thought it was Georgia yeah I thought it was Georgia to
me sat in the council stop it's the slim girl come back to hold me from the
gentle design me protect Padme yeah okay I thought it was Georgia because I
remember like which sport is played by the Detroit Red Wings and the Buffalo
Sabres what the fuck are these I'm gonna say fit ball cuz your fit ball means
rugby so surely the Detroit Red Wings the Buffalo Sabres me and my friends have a
great time doing horse rugby buddy my friends had a great time doing horse
rugby but he still hasn't recovered from it thank you for the super chat let me
pop your super chat cherries all mine now we can do it it's hockey am I just
cheating all the way through this oh like am I just I'm allowed to cheat so I
don't get zapped what if I cheated what if I cheated and looked at chat oh no my
hand slipped I just okay oh no okay I want you in the next one for this one
come on give it to me give it to me I'm literally on 11 okay Teehee right if you
ask for escargo you would receive snails escargo means slow slow three my
brain is what you would describe as escargo it's slowly I knew that one Teehee
and which Italian fencer is a six-time Olympic gold medalist
right okay we're doing the 50-50 hold on no let's do phone a friend right let's
call a friend if it's whamming sport we need to call a whamming because
Negi watches whamming sport unless it's volleyball hey and you know how you're
retired because you slipped and fell and got that case so now you stay at home
all the time watching TV I'm gonna need your advice on this one okay
Sophia go Gia no way her reigns like no that's not how you say it go Gia get all
Gia Gia go Gia that'll do right come on and come through for me I swear if I get
shocked because my aunt gave me the wrong answer I'm gonna be a region okay just
choose the Italian real this courier
you fucking I'm a brah bear what's the point of the little life lines and said
see why did I say a then why did I say a am I just special am I special did she
not tell me a why am I right it says 11 okay okay this is 11 special with the
sea literally though right okay three two one oh I don't oh I hesitated my brain
pathways have been created when I click this button it's all girl okay oh my
brain pathways have been created I'm scared to hit the button now I'm gonna
have to get you crazy we couldn't hit it for me right the lightning you crazy
cop is okay that's getting sore I'm not sure how much higher I can go thank you
the Bay Lord I'm I'm not sure I'll do it to 12 but I think 12 might be my limit I
think it may be my limit I'm starting to yell like unironically starting to yelp
now I'll try 12 but I'm not sure we're going any higher can we get much higher
yeah I don't know how the ASMR stream is gonna go gonna be honest right let's
start with what does that mean right let's out history is fine hardcore is fine
literature new chance Disney fine entertainment lifestyle what the fuck is
that like TV yeah get away TV we don't want to language I'll take superheroes
I'll take sports get out of here star wars day world food stay because I like
what you would go back down to a level you could stand after 10 strongy please
stop hurting yourself don't worry I wouldn't do it if I couldn't handle it
remember when you want to try a hundred yeah no chance of that I am not trying
that I think the highest I would go is 20 mango get you guys to answer any
mangaka question and in return you will be rewarded for your don't go any higher
you turn into charcoal I'm gonna look like the guy from home alone too when
he gets that is it my 100 will make you unconscious and yeah I'm not doing a
hundred fuck that what is the name for putting up advertising pop pop posters
in an unauthorized place is that a joke fly posting surely but I didn't even know
that had a descriptive like that had a describing word a verb a verb is a
doing word you dumbass and known as no an adjunct what's an adjunct I had a
thing and post and let's go which 619 school 619 thank you we've come to
member please enjoy I do have a membership stream after this one which
I'm I don't know how I'm supposed to show up myself and do a some work which show
with music and lyrics by Jim Jacobs and Warren Casey opened in New York
grease okay has to be great and then you're burning up the quarter mile
grease lightning all the rest based on the words play how many seasons make up
game of thrones 8 because I actually watched it something I know something I
know something I'm sure this has been in a
electrifying stream season wait a season don't say that oh right you mean
cuz you didn't like the ending okay sorry don't say that actually I only
acknowledged that what role did Jim many cricket play Pinocchio is conscious
his enemy his brother what it's no his dad Pinocchio Pinocchio is a puppet but
he's no the enemy a brother or consciousness is either a or d I want
to say this is consciousness because because Pinocchio doesn't know better
right surely because I think he gets swallowed by a whale okay okay we we
that was by the skin of our teeth who were the sea radars of the 18th to the
11th century that invaded and conquered many parts of Europe I love
Greece I'm so glad someone else does my friends I like that movie despite age
oh my mum likes Greece so I watched it growing up I know look get me I'm
Sanjay Dee and then she got bullied in stuff the drawing the dragon wing nine
I said the drawing see if you smash her name together really quickly becomes the
dragon well thank you for becoming a membership please enjoy your rewards and
all that who would see radars can I say something really ignorant I never got
taught about aboriginals until I moved to Australia and I didn't even know the
existence I don't know how terrible that is but yeah literally did never go and a
lick of education about aboriginal people until I actually moved to Australia
and then I was like oh my god that's like a whole new like race unlock I had
no idea I was like oh shit there's more races than you any that's so cool you're
an Aussie now no I'm not being accepted in the country I think my I think I'm
gonna get denied and have to go back to Scotland if I'm being honest that's just
me though that's just me I've not been accepted in the country yet so I don't
have rates to do anything in the country so yeah that's fun that's fun having a
visa dangling over here in the UK in which county is the town of Stroud oh
go and give it a rest oh give it a rest that's ridiculous question in which
county is Stroud residing in do you know how many counties are in this
country that's a joke beyond belief here at Cambridge Shire where East Sussex
West Sussex goes to share Devon like bruv that is a joke that is a joke of a
question that is impossible that is literally impossible hold on let's do
us audience need some help here I y'all better hurry up and give me them
answers like that is a joke D Gloucester Shire who'd who'd even tend that so I'm
choosing D who'd even in that honestly that's like oh oh name where Cornwall is
on the map like no one can date unless you're from there that wasn't even like
oh here's a capital of a country no here's a region of a very specific part
of the country gonna be realistic Baroness Marie Christine Vaughn rib
Niz is better known by what name oh it's Marie Curie is that Marie Curie I
think it might be she discovered DNA and then her husband claimed he did but
she was the one that got radiated and everything oh right okay I just made
up I made up I made up I made it over seriously Stroud has a population of
13,000 people nice job I got right I remember Marie Curie's like Laura's
like she discovered the DNA like the the actual sequence no the sequence like the
A to B or whatever I forgot about it's been well and oh fuck sake I forgot I had to do
the shopping for hold on let me drink some water first it's a pharmacist and oh
wait did she about getting it wrong not DNA she discovered radiation but the
women who discovered DNA did get commands okay okay okay okay okay
Marie Curie does not exist wait what I'm having crazy she discovered radiation is
this game made by Brits what's all the UK trivial so you can pick a region and
obviously I picked Britain that's responding but it's fucking horrifically
backfired because apparently I'm supposed to know a fucking region of only
13,000 who goes there oh my god I'm gonna throw up I'm getting nervous okay
it's fine right this is 12 I don't I think we're gonna go back down after this
if I can't handle it oh it's a character from Fallout 4 the game
brain roll is real did you say where I spawned in absolutely my good sir right
ready oh god I'm hesitating that's when you know my my feet are in hands are
really sweaty like I wish I had like some sort of item that could portray how
sweaty my feet are hold on like I bought this box I don't know if you can hear the
stick of my feet against the box just need to prove it you know I just need to
prove it right okay okay just tightening the old strap okay three two one okay
okay okay okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay why is the fucking prongs
hot it's okay it's okay that didn't that actually didn't I don't think I did that
one properly I'm gonna be honest I'm gonna bring it up my thigh a bit and
I'm gonna do it again because that didn't if this if this is really strong I
think I'm not wearing it properly okay okay three two one oh my god I'm
hesitating stop three two one send it okay okay yeah definitely had a wrong
that time yep yep had it on wrong that time that yeah you know that one time
yep had it on wrong I don't wrong we need okay wait I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay you
need no more oh no I don't take this every single time get fat ball here get
out here do stuff I know right now but only stuff I know history all alone
general cult yo I don't know that's generic get TV series out here no if the
prongs are hot that's bad wait hold on let me touch them oh wait I'm an idiot the
prongs aren't hot it's my skin you won't be no no I'll stay on 12 how about that
I'll stay on number 12 I mean there has to be an actual punishment it was the
point he was the point of the concept of the stream of an
no go below boy you want 10 again all right I'm on 10
one level every wrong answer is down one every two or three right answers to a
limit of course I put on 10 speaking of 10 thanks for your attention thank you
I put on 10 okay we don't like seeing you hurt you're a mess I don't think I'm
that bad in 1969 film was titled butch butch Cassidy and the Sundance
reflans can I just cheat what even is this what a film was titled what what see
kid butch Cassidy and the Sundance right answer and therefore a bizarre thing
truly according to the rest of cats what does the cat know knows where it's at
everybody wants to be a cat because the cat's the only cat that knows where it's
waiting for me to answer this your final answer got it right I knew that one
because of our mr. shit where was celebrity chef Gordon born I didn't
can I say American you might know cuz he swears like a British person I see
scottish born
is a
he doesn't send that question am I going mental wait so Jamie Oliver's the
brit is the English one and then Gordon Ramsey's the Scottish one am I going
mental and saying he doesn't he seems like he's Scottish like that's a mental
but he doesn't seem that Scottish to me like he is from glisco right he's
adapted America I think every clip I see him he is in America and like he's
trying to fix American restaurants which is probably why I'm like oh all right I
didn't know that maybe I should support him a bit more he's famous for his rage
I thought I was thinking like I only came from the rage but he's always like in
American restaurants like you've got rats there's rats dropping you've got this
you've got that like all that mani toba and Nova Scotia are provinces of which
country
is it Canada I want to say it's Canada Nova Scotia sounds like Canada
the
is
Canada which of the following are a pair of Disney cartoon characters
I love Chippendale they're two little chipmunks and one has a red
I don't know what the other had to do with it.
Level 5 Wood Elf, Sr.
Thank you for becoming a member.
I hope you enjoy all the yamots.
Hey, we're actually doing a membership after this.
Good timing.
Clap clap, go clap.
Give me that go clap, give me that go clap.
What does Mardi Gras literally mean?
A free something?
Wait, wait, whoa, whoa, whoa.
This isn't French?
Mardi Gras?
Wait, this isn't French?
Mardi.
Vendredi.
Wait, Fat Tuesday?
No, try me.
It is French.
Vendredi.
Mercredi.
Mardi.
No?
Is it Fat Trude Gras?
Yes.
Butchou, stay in it.
Yeah, oh my god, we translated that.
We translated that.
Roots to the wind.
Oh my god.
I'm so surprised we could do that one.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
What the heck, why are we so smart?
Like seriously, I'm really private of that one.
Sorry, I'm really happy with that one.
The title dog in the anime
it found Clifford's big red dog
has what color for?
Oh, well Clifford's red dog is a British thing.
Sunny, welcome to the Ritling.
Please enjoy the emotes.
There's more on the way and one of them
I'm giving you a big smooch.
That will be my final answer.
Nomnage 3, Monsieur.
Je voudrais menager 3
avec deux messieurs.
Clifford the big red dog.
I'm good to keep my cool and it paid off.
And it paid off?
Any payer offer?
Yay, what?
We have Pokemon questions.
Can you just constantly give me Pokemon questions?
For real, for real, because they're not going to do anything past Gen 5
because of the development of this game.
And I know everything before Gen 5.
Roughly.
Onyx is a rock type Pokemon
and it's the only rock type and nothing else.
Which is a shame.
Give me more Pokemon please.
Give me all the Pokemans.
Okay, it's a rock.
In British history, what relation
was King George to Queen Elizabeth?
Some sort of ancestral
vibe is what I'm going to get.
If you've ever looked into the royal family,
it's all interest, all the way down.
Strong, you can't just speak French like that.
You sound nice when you do it.
Ha ha.
Oh, it's you.
Tu voudrais
parler avec moi?
What, you're like my French, aren't you?
I'm all done here when I'm speaking
when I'm on the parler vous la france
Francais, you know.
I'm all the way up here.
In British history, what was the relation?
Grandfather.
It may be grandfather, you actually know that wrong.
I totally cheat, he did a little look to the chat
so if it's not grandfather, you're getting wrecked.
Can't spell ancestry without incest.
Is this your final answer?
Onyx is rock background.
I thought he was rock only.
Hmm.
You know what?
Whoever said is it D.
Mods, time that man out for 10 whole seconds.
Oh, it's a disaster.
Get that man, Mods.
10 seconds.
Sick of him.
I'm getting shocked because of your
foolish ambitions. Put them to rest.
How dare you!
Hup the it.
10 whole seconds, exactly.
Slice them and dice them.
Okay.
Ready?
Okay, this is 10 so I think it won't be as bad.
Right, okay.
I'm gonna set up. I need to set up for this.
What? Okay, 3, 2, 1.
Oh, okay.
It's still quite as bad.
I'm gonna be honest, it's still quite as bad.
I actually see additional content.
I'm gonna go to the DLC store.
Give them 10 whole lashes.
Right, solo.
Right, now.
I'm gonna play a new version of this game.
You guys have to come together
and answer the question.
If you guys give me the wrong question,
everyone gets timed out.
I'm literally gonna open up the stream
so I can do the timeouts as well.
And if we do not win
a normal Mod based on
your votes,
I will manually time you out
along with my moderation team
and you're all getting timed out.
I'll make myself clear, but I'll still get shocked.
I'll still get shocked,
but you're all getting timed out as well.
Forgive me the wrong answer.
Mods, put the shock collar on that replay.
Thank you for the extended membership.
No, no cheating.
It has to be collective knowledge.
No cheating.
Okay, let me set this up.
So if I don't know what it is,
I will ask chat and if we get it wrong,
right, everything gets unlocked.
Everything gets unlocked, okay?
Because we need to do it fair and square.
Everything is unlocked.
I did a little bit of not knowing.
Sorry, you're okay.
You're forgiven.
Big brains will close.
Yeah, no cheating.
It has to be our collective knowledge, okay?
It has to be our collective knowledge.
Okay, who is Scrooge's nephew?
We know it's Donald Duck.
I know the answer.
That's fine.
Good, good, good, good.
What is normally seen above a pair of crossbones
in the Jolly Roger?
A skull.
As I said, if I already know it,
then we'll do it.
Attila was the king of the hunt?
Oh, hold on a minute.
Let me do it.
The Huns?
Okay, okay, okay, you guys seem confident.
I know the answer.
Attila the king of the Huns.
But not the Mongolian throat singers.
Don't get them confuzzled, okay?
Good luck.
Which of these utensils is best
for serving Maligat al-Wini?
Borsh or Gazpacho?
A ladle?
Okay.
Okay, I'm getting ladle.
Okay, but I'm getting ladle.
We're doing ladle, thank you.
I don't know what Gorsapacho is,
but it is what it is.
Well, in my opinion.
Could you imagine if we got it wrong?
Can you move a little bit to the right?
How dare you ask me so kindly?
Hold on, that needs to be...
There.
In an infamous
World
World WBA
boxing match, mate Tyson
took a bait of someone's ear.
Yeah, his ear.
The bait of...
The bait of 97?
Yeah, his ear.
Okay.
Hmm.
Which of these animals shares his name
with a tiger lily?
Surely it's saying tiger lily, right?
Right.
It's saying tiger lily.
Yeah, tiger.
Okay, come.
See, look how much farther we're getting
because you guys are gating me.
Literally, I'm holding your hand.
Yesterday I held your hand through the hypnosis.
Today you're holding my hand through the questions.
Um...
I hope you... Oh, I keep reading what he says.
Which popular cocktail
contains a mixture
of avocat
and lemonade.
Uh, any alcoholic reeflings
lurking that could help us out here?
Uh...
Oh, what in the scubity?
I've got one C.
Oh, it's C.
My mum makes these.
Right! It's all on you
and your mum.
It's all on you and your mum.
Let's go with the right answer and therefore
it's all on you and your mum.
You sure?
If this is wrong, I have full permission
to bang your mum and she's making me a
language after.
It's all on you.
The choice is made.
It's time to discover the right answer.
All on you.
Wow, okay.
Your mother will remain bangless
for one more day.
On which date
is Canada's national day?
Oh,
reeflings that have a leaf!
A fucking leaf!
What is it?
C? C.
July 1st.
Okay, reeflings, thank you.
I'm going to choose C.
You seem to be convinced, but
is this your final answer?
April Fool.
Yes, that's my final answer.
Cluck, cluck, cluck.
Okay.
To American for this, sorry mate.
Will you be able to answer this
new question as well?
Yeah,
insert Terry
Pratchett's
fantasy novel series,
Discworld is balanced
on the back of a
what four animals?
Elephants?
I've never seen that one.
I'm confident that it's me.
Okay, we're picking C.
Super duper elephants.
God, you guys are so smart.
What the heck? How do you know all of this?
It's based on some Hindu stuff.
Oh, that would have been me.
16,000 quid!
We can put a down payment
on a shed in the UK, let's go.
Put a down payment on that shed
and we can get fish and chips too.
Short work of this new question.
What nationality
was the artist
Hiro Nymes Bosch?
So Bosch is a washing machine brand
and I think it comes
from Norway, is my guess.
No, not that.
We've got Dutch.
Literally who? Oh, we've got Swiss.
Dutch, we've got C question mark.
We've got a few C's.
Some's Dutch.
I'll have some
Netherlands.
Netherlands, Monning.
It's BF, but is this your final answer?
Monning is plural.
That will be my final answer.
Okay, okay.
Look at us go in there, 2,000.
Take away for all tonight.
Take away for all.
Everyone is getting lined up and milk
one by one.
Look at each other in the eyes while it's happening.
Just let me do my thing.
Which EastEnders actor, partner?
Oh, British Reflings.
Good morning.
Good evening.
Please tell me.
Which EastEnders actor partnered?
Partnered Hannah Cartoon on the BBC Strictly Come Dancing.
I'm American.
I don't watch EastEnders.
Someone says C.
Someone says A.
I don't know.
Oh my God.
Are there any British Reflings called Tealings?
Any Tealings?
B.
Oh, you're all saying conflicting things.
Right, okay.
We're going to do the 50-50.
We're still allowed to do the 50-50.
Okay.
Let's take away from the 50-50.
I mean, take it from there.
I'm not British.
There's no British, right?
Tealings?
Tealings, please.
It's a fifth.
I sell milk.
Not getting milked.
D.
I'm not British.
A.
Hello.
D.
There are no British.
The British, I don't know.
I'm British, and I don't know.
I'm British, but I don't watch Strictly Come Dancing.
I used to watch it with my gran.
It was so fun.
Brit here hate TV.
Felt that.
Felt that while passing.
When I moved out into a flat,
I used to get hounded with letters through the door,
threatening for someone to come and check
if I've got a TV or not.
And then I hate BBC and everything.
I'll die on A.
I'm British.
It's D.
British here, it's D.
D.
Oh, it's going, right.
I'm going for the D.
I'm a gambler.
And so I'm choosing D.
I'm going for D.
Are you absolutely sure?
Please, no more shocks.
Is that your final answer?
I'm begging, begging you.
And that's my final answer.
I hate the TV license.
Oh, I can't wait to see the correct answer.
Oh, Bruce Lee!
Right, whoever said D, you're out.
Hold on, let me freaking ban you all right now.
D, D, trust in the Brits.
Oh, that was the wrong answer.
Put user and time out.
10 seconds confirmed.
Right, I'll die on D.
Put user on time out, 10 seconds.
Get out of here!
Anyone else had the audacity to say D?
Okay, you did it.
Okay, everyone's been caught.
Everyone's been caught.
Brits say it's D.
Well, guess what?
You said D as well, so you're getting put in time out.
10 seconds, get out of here!
Get out of here!
You made me get zapped!
We said A, no, there was more Ds!
You made me get zapped.
I'm American and I got it right.
I was at 50, 50.
Okay, no more.
Everyone's been timed out, that was naughty, okay?
Everyone's been timed out, that was naughty.
Okay, time for a controlled shock to Foxy.
Okay.
Come at it, okay.
We still got further than you, how dare you, okay?
Three, two, one.
Oh, I'm hesitating.
The pathways have been created.
That button equals pain,
so my brain doesn't wanna do it anymore.
Okay, three, two, one.
Okay, okay, I did it, I did it, I did it, I did it.
It's fine, it's fine, I did it.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm on 10.
32 was the highest score,
and we got as far as Bronzo, hell yeah, you did.
Okay, well we try again.
Surely we can win on normal mode,
if not we'll do easy mode when we start running at a time.
Wait, without a timer, go away.
I don't know, can I wanna take all the stuff
that none of us know?
Can we maybe remove one category?
What one?
I've already entered.
I've entered the layer.
Need Footy to survive, real.
I have failed you.
Which of these phrases describes
a restless and fidgety person answering his pants?
Let's go with the right answer, and therefore,
No, keep them all, I've been banned.
I'd have banned Footy.
More manga trivia, real.
Who is not friends with Harry Potter
when Harry got to Hogwarts?
Everyone, he had just got there,
and he was, he pals with anyone.
Well, Draco and Aggard was nice dumb, so it was Draco.
I'm confident that it's C.
Potter, we're Potter, Harry Potter.
Are you sure you've got them?
I'm so good at it.
Which of these words is the German equivalent?
Ge zonheit, ge zonheit, ge zonheit.
Oh no, achu schnell, achu glasnost, achu verbose.
Achu, ge zonheit.
I don't know why I added a bit of Dutch on the back of that one.
Ge zonheit.
What was the first name taken by the playwright Big William,
who wrote Cat on a Hot Tin Roof?
Huh?
Who?
Ge zonheit.
Hurry up and sneeze.
Oh.
Someone said D.
D maybe?
I think it's B or D.
Right, well 50-50 to remove the answer.
You wouldn't, you wouldn't get mummy shocked again so quickly,
no, would you, Reefling?
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
D, D, delta, delta.
I had a freaking heart attack there.
It's delta, oh my god.
Oh my god, thank god it let's you like lock in.
Woah, saved, saved, it's okay.
Whose heart rate is going higher?
Mine are yours right now, be honest.
How many events are there in this sporting competition
called a deck athelon?
Now, you've got an ino athelon, a duo athelon,
a tri athelon, a quarter athelon,
a quintet athelon, a six athelon,
a sept athelon, an octagothelon,
a nano-necolon, and a decathlon, which is 10.
Yippee.
I'm going to choose.
I tried really hard.
I tried so hard.
I didn't say anything right, but yes.
Yippee.
I see a athelon.
Real.
Okay, new question.
What was the name of the first?
Dolly the sheep.
I know this one.
Dolly the sheep was the first ever publicly revealed clone.
Now, just to remind you, odds are Dolly
and any other previous cloning was made many years ago.
That includes humans too.
And that's not tinfoil hat theory.
That is true.
Which of these is a type of computer file
used to customize websites for individual?
What?
What even?
Which of these?
What?
It's A, a cookie.
Oh, cookies when I ask you for your cookies.
Okay.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I'm choosing A.
Sorry, my bad.
I understand.
Cookies.
That's when you type in.
Be a lure.
You type in a Zura delay on Google search.
Then when you go on YouTube,
it'll push Azura's content to you more.
Yeah, that's how it works.
Surely.
And what season of the series Breaking Bad
does the character Saul Goodman appear for the first time?
I want to say season two because, you know,
he didn't need legal help until,
because season one was about a set.
I want to say it's two because season one's about setting up the premise,
but he didn't need the legal help until later, right?
Surely.
Copium.
I never watched it.
It was pretty early.
I can't remember B, B, B.
Okay, B, I'm going with you.
I would say B.
I'm going with you.
B.
I'm going with the refling.
Because the reflings are right.
That's my final answer.
And they're not wrong.
And we'll get along.
You have given your final answer.
And you'll take off my thong.
Okay.
Thank you.
Which team eliminated Real Madrid in the Champions League of 2006?
Borough.
Barcelona.
Any, any football reflings?
Any footlings?
I'm American.
I don't know.
Okay.
It's so over.
British reflings, come on.
There has to be one a year.
Thong is Aussie for a flip-flop.
It is.
Soccerlings.
That's fit ball.
And Scots is fit ball with an I.T.
Like a fit ball we're done for.
I say A or B.
A or B.
Okay, okay.
Hold on.
We also have in-game help.
Let's ask the audience in-game as well.
Okay.
If you would pick up those keypads.
We have Arsenal.
Did anyone think Arsenal?
Whatlings fit ball?
Whatlings fitlings?
Like if I,
fit balllings,
we say fit.
Isn't it?
Fit ball.
D,
are we going with D?
Arsenal.
You know I heard of Arsenal before.
There's a football team called Arsenal.
Yes.
Literally.
It's called Arsenal.
Right.
Okay.
We're doing it.
I guess D.
Okay.
Whoever said D,
it's Ogre.
It's Ogre.
I'm a gambler.
And so,
I'm choosing D.
It's Ogre.
Is that your final?
Am I getting that?
Yes.
Be honest.
That's my final answer.
If this is your final answer,
let's hope it's the correct answer.
I'm Scott Senneth.
I watch the fit ball.
Okay.
We're safe.
The audience didn't tell us Fiverrini's.
Right.
Which toy are you?
It's said to take its name
from a B.
Corbin.
Oh,
it's a B.
Yeah.
It's a B.
One two three,
two one two one two,
two and three one two,
two and three.
I am.
Abacare in Connecticut.
A Bakery in Connecticut.
Any Connecticut reeflings,
any Connecticut
lings?
What Bakery?
Definitely not Lego.
No,
that's copyright by far.
Any Connecticut
lings?
Literally,
what toy you said to take its name
from a bakery in Connecticut.
Bee, a Frisbee?
A Frisbee?
Okay, we've got a few bees, we've got a few bees.
I'll allow it.
I've got a Frisbee.
Go for it.
Oh!
I'm giving you a golf clap as well.
Fantastic effort, leaflings.
I like when you use that brain power together.
What is the name of a puppeteer
that tricks Pinocchio and locks him in a kit?
Oh, for goodness sake, I don't even know.
Stromboli, isn't that a type of food?
Am I going mental and saying that's a type of food?
Wait, Stromboli's the answer?
I thought Stromboli was food, like ravioli.
Well, you guys are same seed, I'm a trustee.
Stromboli is the Pinocchio.
Has kind of root names.
Oh my.
And that's my final answer.
Oh yeah.
Oh.
Okay, it's Stromboli.
Look at my refunds, oh my god.
We might actually win.
Who is our Lowe's father in the 2015 movie,
The Good Dinosaur?
Refluence, this one's for you, take it away.
Stromboli, are you saying a story character
wouldn't be named a food?
Something.
You guys are too mixed up.
We've got C, D and B and C again.
Oh my god, oh shoot, where?
D and C.
Right, okay, you guys are split.
You don't know this one, I don't know either.
Shawnee, this is Disney.
I ain't seen The Good Dinosaur,
we're like all the Dino,
we're like Dino dead from an asteroid.
Ha ha.
Why was that the quietest cricket I've ever done?
We're a phone friend, I don't know either.
D?
D, okay.
It looks like D's winning.
Oh, I was gonna say Henry sounds like D.
Do you want white women to help us?
Right, okay, white women help us.
You decide to play the lifeline.
Hydration check, replayings, okay.
Hope you will call the right person.
What is The Good Dinosaur?
I've got an idea, honestly,
your guess is as good as mine.
Childhood friend, Andy, surely you've watched this movie?
Surely.
Surely, copy him, copy him.
Good evening, Andy.
It's who wants to be in the-
He says D as well, I think you've got it then.
Okay, D, on route to the win.
Okay, I think you've got it.
Okay, okay, perfect.
That's what we like to eat.
Whoa!
And go on to the next one.
Oh my gosh.
Think of all the-
Take a look.
Think of all the food I can fatten you up with.
At the pace you're going,
you're going to make short work of this-
And what country makes you be served
a soup called Mo-
You know?
What?
Any ESL links?
Calling upon you.
ESL links?
Any ESL links?
I've got a B.
That's at least five.
A looks like Borderlands antagonist, real.
Check the tank, I don't live in that room.
We need a Filipino.
It's not D.
Okay, we've got not D.
We've got Charlie.
Lowell.
No, you are all right now.
See each other.
We've got three C's.
We've got one A thrown in there.
It's not looking good.
A C maybe?
We've got another C.
It sounds like an interesting stream.
It's torture, let's see.
Burma.
Burma pants, sorry.
Let's see.
A bear me's co-worker brought it in for lunch.
Okay.
Anyone who says C gets the wrong,
you're out of here for 10 seconds.
You understand me?
You're out of here.
Come on.
Come on Burma.
Come on Burma, try and go.
Oh my God.
You guys are actually gonna.
We're winning the million.
I think we're winning the million.
We may actually win, no way.
We may actually win with our collective brain power.
Woo!
Oh no, it's a TV show.
Well, that was close enough.
Where is the Glasgow Setsope River City actually filmed?
I didn't watch the TV, so this is useless.
No, it's not a strong question.
I don't watch the TV.
I didn't pay my license.
I didn't pay none of that.
River City.
Why would it?
I mean, I don't usually watch beach over streams
because, but this is entertainment.
Yeah, you're like when I shocked myself.
Is that when your entertainment value went up?
Exactly, I got you in 4K.
I thought you were Scottish.
Yes, I am, I spawned there.
But I didn't watch the TV.
I've never watched the TV.
I've always played video games.
I wanna say, please.
A, Dumbarton shouldn't pay for a license.
You have never watched the critically acclaimed TV series.
River City is not critically acclaimed.
I can tell you that much.
Okay, well, it's no Glasgow.
So pick A or C.
Dumbarton?
Dundee is like kind of like a wee bit R.A.
But is it a film production?
I don't think so.
You're Scottish.
Name every Scott right now.
Imagine having the license for a TV.
Apparently you have to do it in Japan as well.
I don't know.
I got A's.
I see a lot of A's.
I think I'm out of lifelines.
I can skip the question.
Will we skip it for when we're more caught?
I think we skip it and pick something
that we're more likely to, no, save the skip.
Oh my God.
It's, nah, A.
If it's no Dumbarton,
I know the answer.
If it's no Dumbarton, you're all done for.
And I need to fart.
So the next time I shock myself,
if you hear me fart, no one's blaming me for it, okay?
She wanted to use the skip on a Scottish question.
If it was like, name the fucking Falkirk wheel.
Oh, thank God it's Dumbarton.
Literally.
Oh my God, we have half a million.
We can literally get the castle like right now.
I'm not even kidding.
Last question, Reflins.
Surely.
Surely, Reflins.
Oh, no farts.
No farts.
But you shouldn't stop there.
Here is a new question.
In 1985, Clive Pointon was charged with leaking details
of the sinking of the Belgrano to whom?
Who?
What?
Where?
When?
And why?
Skip this.
Literally, there has to be one autistic Reflin for the answer
or this is a full skip.
I think this is a, I think this is a full skip.
Literally, everyone's like who, what, where, why, when?
Okay, full skip.
So let's change the question.
A flip lifeline, well, you.
Okay, what's gonna be the new question?
Is it George Galway?
Oh no, I would have got it wrong.
I would have said Big George.
Yeah, that we hardly any of us knew what that was.
Okay, new last question.
I'm Pokemon autistic, not this autistic Real.
I hope you ever recovered from your emotions.
I've not.
Because here is your new question.
I'm a woman, sorry.
In the fall of 2007,
epiti-peti-peti-peti became which country's first astronaut?
Any spacelinks?
Any nasolings?
Surely, surely one of us.
Someone says Saudi Arabia.
Oh, actually, from the name alone, you might be right.
You might be right with the name.
Yeah, you might be right with the name, I'm gonna be honest.
It's either B or C.
I don't, it's not an Egyptian name.
Okay, I'm gonna poll it and chat.
Wait, so people are saying A, Malaysia?
Don't let the name fool you.
Oh no, are we being stereotypical racists on a Friday night?
Oh, we're saying Malaysia now.
I see a lot of A.
Yeah, I see A.
Right, I'm gonna have to poll it.
Holy crap, hold on.
Hold on, start a poll, answer.
That was me if you heard that.
That was my desktop, not yours.
Answer A, B, or C.
Start poll, go.
You can now vote in a poll on, in chat.
Malaysia is very Arabic, is it?
I thought Malaysia was Asian.
Am I being Papago and I just don't know anything?
What are we looking at?
Oh wow, A is winning out of the wazoo.
All in on A, okay, all in on A.
I trust you with my life, Reflings.
Surely you wouldn't shock me.
You sure?
Oh, yes, that's my final answer.
Surely, surely temples.
If this is your final answer,
surely temples.
Let's hope it's the correct answer.
Yes!
Our freaking collective smarts!
Oh, our collective smarts, we did it!
Yes, we earned a million smakarines.
Now I can make the milking farm
and put you all to work
whilst we have bountiful harvest
and chickens and all that in the gift and stuff.
Oh, we did it, Reflings, you guys are so smart.
How dare you, how dare you be so smart.
Now go in hard mode, wait, is there a hard mode?
There's no way.
Is there a hard mode?
Solo, normal, easy and quick.
This game mode is mainly composed of tag.
Well, what do you want to do?
Do you want to do an easy round?
Do you want to do a quick round or?
Or will I just turn it up to 20 and hit it?
Be honest.
I need to buy quick round or hard modes?
Oh, sorry, I'm just looking at my leg.
I've got like a little, like what?
Oh my God.
My leg looks like it has chicken pox,
but it's the collar leaving marks.
Oh my God, I have marks on my leg.
I didn't know it did that.
I thought it was like a no marks left behind kind of thing.
Am I special needs?
I think I might be.
I didn't know they left a mark.
I want, right, can we just say fuck it
and I'll do it on 20 and if I fart, then you'll win.
And then that'll be the last shock.
Well, I'm gonna do ASMR.
Oh no, I'm too scared to put it up to 20.
I'm too much of a baby.
You're so special.
I'm terrible.
I have no idea what 100 would be capable of.
That's absolutely insane.
20 seems way too high.
Maybe the straps are too tight.
It's just maybe pushing into me.
It's what you baby, nice job, Strani.
We did it, we made a million.
Any gazillionaires?
Right, I'll do 15.
This one's for you, baby.
Okay, we'll do 15.
Okay, ready?
Ready?
If I fart, you win is crazy sentence.
Okay, last one and then I'm gonna go offline
and redirect you guys.
And then for those who are a member,
I'm going to take five minutes
just to set up the ASMR.
And then we're obviously not gonna be doing ASMR
if I'm shocking myself whilst trying to do,
you know, tingles and stuff.
Okay, this is 15.
Okay, I'll mute the background game
just so you can really get the full experience of my scream.
All right, you ready?
Three, I'm so nervous, my heart is beating.
Three, two, one.
I'm hesitating, I'm so scared.
I'm scared, right?
And go, go, go!
Oh my God, I'm hesitating so badly, I can't do it.
Oh my God, I need you to push the button
reflint unironically.
Right, it's kind of just blinking at me as well.
Right, three, two, one.
Okay, okay, okay, yay, I'm not doing that again.
Let's go right back on down, back on down.
I did it.
Just as a PSA for this stream,
please do not ever use shock callers on any pet or animal.
It is very unethical.
It's not very nice thing to do.
And the animal does not know better.
You're teaching a pathway of pain
to prevent it from doing a behavior
rather than doing rewarding behaviors
such as if it is a good-
Are you squidding me right now?
Then it's good, strongy-
Good girl, strongy that was in good session.
No, what did I even learn?
We'll only use the shock callers, you did good.
Shock callers are only for subsequent, real insurance.
You made it sound like getting shot from a needle.
It is sore, like don't do it, whatever you do, don't do it.
Here, how about you just fart and then sign off?
That would be absolute Chad behavior.
Can I do that on like my last ever stream?
I just part my cheeks on the mic
and just let one rip and I'll be like,
that one's for you, brat bros.
I know you were waiting an entire time.
The way you struggled did something to me.
I was like, I'll eat this, but one guy is.
You learned to trust Chad, I do.
Call them bad boys.
You've been a bad boy, Wiefling.
You've not given me enough ink supply.
Time for the shock caller.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, what?
Last stream, don't leave it.
No, I'm not leaving.
Stop it, you giveoes.
Stop it, you're gonna upset yourselves.
You know what it reminds me of?
You know what it reminds me of
when like children upset themselves
to the point they throw up?
That's what I think when you guys are having a carry on
being like, mommy's leaving, mommy's leaving.
Oh, sugar, she be doing a watch along yet.
Okay, we will see if we can redirect into someone.
Is anyone online?
Cause there's like, never anyone online when I'm online,
honestly, you're all getting done for.
You're all getting done for, okay?
Hold on, I'm just gonna check that this VTuber
isn't doing what I think she's doing.
If she's doing what I think she's doing,
unfortunately I can't redirect into her,
but if she's doing her own thing, that's different.
Hold on, I need to make sure it's muted, hold on.
Oh, unfortunately I can't redirect
into the content.
Okay, Raincloud is on.
Let's redirect into Raincloud.
For those who are members, give me five minutes.
I'm trying to redirect into someone,
but someone's streaming something
that I can't interact with.
I think it's up.
Mook Askela, thank you for coming to member.
For those of you who are a member,
I am going to set up an ASMR stream in T minus five minutes.
I'm gonna make a cup of tea and go for a pee,
maybe try and squeeze out a loaf of bread while I'm at it,
but I'll be five minutes.
I will keep the shop caller for the ASMR.
I don't know how it's gonna go,
but it's gonna go all right.
Thank you so, so much for tuning in.
I had so much fun.
I will see you goofy givers tomorrow for endurance.
We might get 99 cooking in RuneScape tomorrow.
You're welcome to hang out with me.
We'll be in Edgeville Bank as always.
We'll be edging in Edgeville.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Please don't worry.
No, don't throw up because you're sad now.
Okay, right.
I'll see you tomorrow.
And if you're a member,
I'll see you in five minutes
after I've tried to squeeze out a little baguette.
Thank you for the tips,
Ronnie's trainer, outrageous comment,
but very funny and I like that.
So there you go.
I'll see you tomorrow,
but first things first.
Did you enjoy me shocking myself?
Be honest.
And I'll give you another kiss.
Teal, thank you for coming on a member.
You did, I knew it.
I'm on to you.
I'm on to you, but I'll get ready for my ASMR stream
for membership, okay?
I'll be back, but see you tomorrow.
If I don't see you through a window,
I'll see you while you're wanking in your bed.
Love you, bye, Reflings.